ça va les conneries malheureux
ok ils ont ça se fait qu'on n'entend
rien à
vous et avec un portable dans la
non mais parce que là on est en train de
faire des réglages
sur la cabine et là vous êtes au
téléphone avec un portable 1
et 1,5 seconde
année s'est téléphoné oui dans mais là
on entend tout parce que c'est une
vérité sur écoute c'est pour ça et moi
je fais des réglages
d'accord c'est raison des baisses
constamment longtemps détour par étonné
on est sur écoute pas tout le temps
c'est ça marche pas mal ah ouais bah
c'est pas la faute à manches à rien
peut-être celio telle une à plein temps
mais c'est celle là qui est sur écoute
c'est bien sûr on ne sait pas combien
on est en écoute je te rappeler leur
cabine parce que là ça part un peu
malsain quand même se séparent comprends
pas bien ce n'est pas malsain et désolé
j'en faisais pas mal du tout mais
surtout comment ça vous ennuie pas
d'écouter les morceaux sont des gens
assez mon métier
pour mature mais je te dois les blacks
ou chiquer albis nous parler trop vite
j'ai pas le temps de tout noté à noter
pas me comprenez pas là bah oui mais je
saigne et salace avons juste receipts
dans l'appareil lorsque je dis oui après
il était le cas qui comprend
certainement on va le passer au
traducteur
oui petit amar qui parlent plus fort
ap voici mon portable attends je mourrai
c'est pareil un des portables aussi un
sens sur écoute je m'en fous monsieur
s'il vous plaît vous permettez longé par
oui ça veut dire soit je suis désolé
pour qui là où vous êtes aux miss à
l'intérieur quoi aux renseignements
généraux grosses mains généraux rg mais
votre avis france télécom ne rend pas du
tout c'est les renseignements généraux
du salon
renseignements du monde ça va pas du
tout dans ces renseignements généraux
c'est la police au moins cinq ans elle
est bon
j'ai été courtois j'entends et vous
casser les pieds ce travail avait cessé
d'ouvrir et de fermer la porte on
s'arrête vous les jeunes et pour deux
minutes ah ouais mais bon il faut bien
que je fasse mes réglages mais j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] bus vous voyez que j'étais
génétiques sur les comptes et donc ne
pas être citée moi la paix je sais pas
mais si tu me vois à la télé
ça pour quoi
[Musique]